if you're a netflix buyer at a market
you're a celebrity like you almost need
security to walk through the marketplace
because
can we go back in time to that first
netflix meeting you had what year was
this
14 or 15 yeah 14 or 15. the first one
was 14 because i hadn't made the movie
yet i made the movie in 15 the first one
so i pitched them before i made the
movie
how did you get that meeting netflix was
a different company back then they
actually you know what i actually phoned
them up
and i emailed i got the name
you could get they published
email addresses like the company wasn't
gigantic
it was big obviously it was still very
big but
it wasn't what it is today and you could
actually get
the names of buyers
and you could email them and they would
actually return an email
so that's what i did i emailed well i
had to email probably 15 or 20 times
um made cut left a couple of voice
messages because you could also get that
and then finally i got a return phone
call and
you know i had done other movies before
so it wasn't my first had it been my
first i probably wouldn't have gotten
them the meeting
that that was my fourth movie um the one
that i pitched them on so i'd already
made three before so i kind of knew what
i was doing i said you know i here's
what i've made here i'm an experienced
filmmaker blah blah blah i've got this
movie you got the olympus coming up can
i pitch you on it so they heard the
pitch but then they said um we can't
take a chance on you until we see the
movie so make the movie and then come
back
but they didn't guarantee anything they
just said make the movie and show it to
us when it's done
so the movie finished yeah how soon
before you're picking up the phone or
emailing after that
the movie wrapped at you know 505 on a
thursday and at 506 i was picking up the
phone
literally okay no no i mean i was i was
just saying okay i'm finished shooting
you know
i didn't show it to them obviously until
after it's finished edited and
everything like that but no no i was
anxious but
again
back then i was depending on it a little
bit more and i was much more hopeful
than i am today in terms of my realism
level
um
so
because i was a little more naive the
truth the truth is i just wasn't as
beaten up as i am now so um i really
really was hoping that they would take
it
um but by the way the movie before that
i made it for disney
and i had i had got into disney and i it
was called king of the camp it was a
kids movie a camp musical just like camp
rock and it was really it was great
movie i loved making it and it was so
disney and i met with the disney channel
twice and we talked about it and i came
really really close so i knew i had the
flavor i had the taste of what it was to
be and
ultimately they said no
um and it broke my heart
but at least i got there at least i had
the pitch and you know i sat in the
disney office and and they watched the
trailer and i saw you know i got to that
and they saw the movie and ultimately
and you know it was it was a fair no i
think it was terrible no to get but as
they say no is the second best answer
um but so so i'd been there done that so
with netflix it was like okay i'm not
going gonna set myself up for
disappointment but i really really
really want this
and and i got lucky
and and it sounds like too there were
ways to get in touch with people that i
mean you said you were incredibly naive
but also there were there was more
access points way more access so there's
no more access like back then it wasn't
like they would not look at unsolicited
material they actually looked at
unsolicited material now it's done it's
finished
they get they're too big they have too
many yeah it's so that what happened
back then does not happen anymore for
obvious reasons
yeah it's so tiny and by the way they
weren't doing any original programming
back then i mean they just probably
started i forget what their first series
was that they made internally but it was
all
all acquisitions so they needed product
so there was a lot look at the year that
i sold them that movie
i can't remember they statistically they
told me i can't remember the number
exactly but they it was something like
they bought 900 independent films that
year and the year i sold them the last
movie they bought 300. oh wow so because
they're making stuff internally right so
they don't need as much external product
as they do now they still need some but
generally it's bigger stuff
so it's gotten harder and by the way
it's funny so i've got three movies on
netflix and i sold them three
i think i have less of a chance now even
having done business with them three
times of actually selling them something
more than i had back then
just because they're so big and they
have so much internal production that
it's gotten even more difficult since
you'd already worked in distribution
didn't you have a number of contacts you
could count on to try to get you in the
door
even after let's say some of the window
closed of their email addresses being
online for you to access them yeah
absolutely no a lot of distribution is
networking and people who worked at one
company often end up in another company
or switch around and you know you keep
hopefully you have your friendships with
them and your business relationships and
and they i do get a lot of pitch
meetings that way because i know people
i mean that's a big component of
distribution as it is in any business
right is networking
so um yeah so i'm not as active in
distribution anymore so i don't have as
many contacts as all newer people and
younger people but the people who i have
known for many years who are still
active i still get meetings
how does one become active in
distribution let's suppose someone's
starting from the ground level and they
want to be able to build that rapport
with people what are some good ways they
can do it themselves so it's funny you
ask that because i i do teach at san
diego state university i teach
filmmaking and i said to a lot of my
students you know
that you might want to consider going
into distribution to start your career
not production
and know that you know in five or ten
years after you do distribution you'll
end up hopefully in production and just
you know make sure you guide yourself in
that direction
that's how you do it you got to work in
it
like you can't expect to be a working
film producer and understand the
distribution circles because you're not
in them you got to work in a
distribution company go to the markets
meet your competitors meet other people
meet buyers
the distribution companies are
constantly meeting with buyers
their drink having drinks and dinner and
all this kind of stuff and meetings and
you get to know these people and you
know and you develop relationships over
time but you have to work in
distribution to develop those
relationships
or go to film markets so buy a pass
no no no no you can go to film markets
and kind of
be on the periphery but you're not going
to get in the inner circles uh i see
yeah no if you really want to get those
relationships you got it like listen a
lot of people go to film markets and
festivals and sit in panels and see the
people and once in a while somebody's
nice enough to answer some questions or
meet afterwards or whatever
but it's not the same you're not
developing that kind of relationship
because you're not doing business
together you're just kind of an irritant
that you're a filmmaker who wants their
attention that's that's the truth you
know
um so they'll if they're polite they'll
give you the time of day
most of them are polite so they don't
bother because they don't you know it's
like being a celebrity everybody wants
your attention and you just don't have
time to give it to everybody
and everybody's going to pitch on the
same thing and just get tired of it
after a while like if you're a netflix
buyer at a market
you're a celebrity like you almost need
security to walk through the marketplace
because everybody is gonna like just
just
divulge you know just jump all over you
they just want your attention for a
second
right
just to clarify the first time you
pitched netflix were you pitching them
an idea or
an actual film a good great question so
the film wasn't made so i guess it's an
idea but the film there was a script
there was the production was ready to go
all the actors were in place i knew
where i was shooting it was just like
pre-production i pitched them at that
phase so the movie i'd already financed
the movie by the way i didn't need them
to finance the movie if the movie was
already financed ready to go ready to be
shot
but i felt like you know had i if i were
to do it again i would pitch them even
earlier this time but but i pitched them
at that point
and
by the way i didn't just pitch netflix i
pitched everybody this wasn't exclusive
netflix was one of the companies i
pitched i pitched in every studio
i mean disney was where i was hoping to
put that movie
full out i mean disney was the target
for it it was you know girl-centric it
was
female empowerment 12 year olds i mean
it's the disney audience frankly i was
shocked that disney didn't buy it disney
bought it for the disney channel for the
rest of the world but not the united
states i was shocked i expected the sale
to come from them
so i'm not disappointed that it came
from netflix as a great customer and
ultimately worked out fantastic they had
a huge huge audience but it was the
disney audience that i was like when i
pitched my investors and they said where
are you like what's your niche audience
who's your niche target i said it's
disney i mean
we're setting up the movie it's a disney
s style movie it attacks their audience
this is who we're going for
so and i had several meetings with them
because i knew the people there
and they just said no and then luckily
netflix said yes but you know i also
pitched pretty well every studio i mean
i had i knew a lot of people like sony
warner
um fox i knew people at all these places
through my distribution days so i was
able to get meetings
um
so that's how it happened um but it
happened just before i made the movie so
there was lots to pitch on and i had
made a promo reel i obviously i couldn't
shoot make a trailer because i hadn't
shot anything yet but i cut a promo reel
almost like a little sort of
three-minute documentary about
who the i'm making the movie about where
i'm shooting it little narration that
type of thing just to make it a little
bit more visually appealing and it was a
good promo reel
did they say why
you wouldn't they didn't want to take on
u.s territory netflix i mean uh disney
i don't they didn't like the movie
they don't tell you why they don't tell
you why okay
and even if they do tell you why it just
make you feel good you know it's
what are they going to say to me it's
not a good movie or it doesn't you know
what you know what they actually they
did say you know what they said they
said it doesn't um
suit our audience
and i said
okay
this is confusing to me number one is
disney channel rest of world
took the movie and it suits their
audience but disney channel usa said it
doesn't suit our audience and then i
said that to them and they said it's a
different audience and i said you're
kidding me
but who am i gonna say what am i gonna
argue i mean you know
i just take everything to mean we don't
like it you know thanks a lot nice try
no matter what they say i just that's
what i hear they could say anything and
i hear
sorry nice try come back tomorrow
yeah i just wasn't sure how much they
told you because that's very fascinating
that they the rest of the world liked it
but the us but i don't believe it you
don't believe it i don't believe i know
first of all i know darn well that that
movie plays to their audience they just
didn't have room for it or whatever
that's what they told me it was you know
whatever they needed to tell me to be
polite and you know and get me out the
door
that movie plays to their audience we
all know it they know it i know it you
know it's the world is not different
that way 12 year old girls are 12 year
old girls everywhere